i don't know if i told you this already
but i got my first dm the other day from
a girl
i got to show you this you did but you
didn't show me should i show you yeah
look at this i couldn't even believe it
i was with my friends
that's
insane and is she real oh my god i love
you
yeah she's here we know she how do we
know does it go it goes back years and
what is it it's like yeah i know it's
real what did she say that's right we
just we dm'd a little bit and then i i
gave her my number that's why it's the
goat [ __ ] out
i just watched your no boys bid and i
think i'm the perfect girl for you
how funny is that no she's catfishing
girls it's not like that do girls talk
like it's a real person stop the cow
and i think i'm the perfect girl for you
it's weird it's definitely a weird thing
that it's like i was like you don't even
know what to say to that but yes next
she's like she's gonna send a bank
account for you to wire money to no
she'll catch a flight to miami if any
that that's that's all i think the
reason a lot of men are so depressed is
because they feel invisible they feel
like
the life is life is too hard women
expect me to be strong and smart and
funny and interesting with a nice
apartment and a fast car and tall and
well connected well they try to tell you
that's not what you need but that is
what you need and then then people
wonder why they're depressed when
they're fat and they have no money
why do they want me
no if they if they promoted doing all
this [ __ ] and you'd get your dream life
then people would do it they'd be more
inclined to it they wouldn't be from
birth used to and like it'd shove down
their throats to live a shitty life like
that yeah some girls like couch potatoes
and they want a fellow spud to chill
with i couldn't possibly find a couch
potato which girls want a guy with
adventure and fire in them for the most
part about the kind of girls that are
interesting and you want to be around
yeah the girls you want to be around so
yeah the social pressure on men is
absolutely immense and i was championing
their issues and at the same time all
these social media platforms pretend to
care as soon as somebody they resonate
with stands up and champions their
issues they mass blanket ban me which
shows they have absolutely no care for
the young men of the world today
they think that by banning me i'm just
going to vanish and the young men are
just going to go and start eating the
gruel that they're fed on their on their
youtube feed they don't want to read
they don't want to see transgender
people wear makeup they don't want to
see that they want to see a man who has
a bunch of money and a nice life and
some fast cars and is strong and is
confident they want an action hero
and that's something that
large portions of the world still want
to be
and and youtube and social media
platforms obviously just don't like the
idea of that why what is so dangerous
about people being successful it is
really it's it's wild and they and they
pretend that they want people to be i
don't even know what they want i don't
even know if successful is the right
word but yeah maybe it is pretending
that they want them to be successful be
free spirit be a free thinker be
yourself you got to be you yeah except
do everything we tell you to do yeah
unless and get offended by the stuff we
tell you to get offended by only if you
agree with us it's just so bonkers and
and to look at somebody that is addicted
to exercise and
helping people and charity and making
money and then [ __ ] on them just makes
no sense i i just can't bribe my i still
i just keep saying all you have to do is
make this out how do you even enjoy life
nobody should be censored let the freaks
run their freak flag up the flagpole who
cares let them go let hate be taped and
let everybody find their niche yeah but
they just don't want you seeing it so
well again we've said it over and over
again i know we've said this a million
times because they want to control us
well but yeah people had the choice to
choose between following tate and
following you know ridiculous stuff that
you see on the internet everyone who
wouldn't want to follow tape you've said
that you prefer living in eastern and
central europe
bucharest and
and in hungary
how are the attitudes that are different
about men do you notice since you
you've lived in the uk the u.s and now
there it's actually very interesting
because the things i say which are
deemed controversial in the west are
completely normal and standardized here
it's completely normal for the idea of
if a family were to go on a long drive
at night in the dark and it was raining
and it was a dangerous road the man
would probably drive delicious that's
accepted over here if i say that in the
west i'm sexist
uh the idea that a man is even though
that's actually the fact nine out of 10
times it's night the dude drives what is
wrong with actually but we can't say it
we can just live it we can't actually
say it out loud because it's sexist why
is that sexist i can't everything oh
these people can't think of enough
things to complain about providing for
his family and physically protecting his
family that's completely accepted over
here in the west i'm i'm a misogynist
it's truly it's truly crazy um the place
i live is not even the reason my views
are what they are
it's just i think a lot of people
actually agree with me
i think it's just a very very vocal
minority which have decided to purport
this idea that i hate women i don't know
in how many ways to state that i don't
hate women there's no evidence i hate
women no women are coming forward saying
i've ever done anything there's no
evidence at all it's just tick tocks
edited up to make me look bad made by
people i don't know
and the media latching on to it and
deciding you know what
kovid's over and everyone's board of
ukraine so let's hey andrew tate for a
while and hopefully next week they'll
find something else to talk about but
it's truly asana they tried to cancel
joe rogan that didn't work yeah good
luck with that who else have they tried
to cancel chappelle i mean give me a
break they tried to cancel chappelle
that was so funny even netflix which
went full woke for a couple of years all
the [ __ ] they make so much money off of
him that they were like they were not
canceling him no matter what went on in
fact they changed their employee policy
to say hey if you don't like it we need
we're going to actually have diversity
of thought and if you don't like it
maybe this isn't the place for you
because at the end of the day money
matters and they're starting to see that
but well yeah they're just stock awful
like limited so yeah they're just
there's a lot a lot of people that it
doesn't work anymore canceling doesn't
work anymore they fired a bullet and it
and it bounced off his skull my titanium
skin and banning me from social media as
we've discussed is is bad for the world
i truly believe that
and i really think it was a mistake and
i think it was a mistake because i think
this is the first time the social media
companies have banned someone for a
non-political reason
and it's really got a lot of the young
people of the world thinking now
and they're sitting and thinking going
okay well the politics stuff that's kind
of like you know
older stuff but
why are they banning him like why are
they is this what they do
influential even alex jones is saying
like a lot of really crazy stuff even
though i've listened to him and i i know
a lot of what people don't like him for
is taken out of context he does say a
lot of crazier stuff so i'm not as
surprised by them banning alex jones but
tate it's really just ridiculous because
he's promoting men just doing good stuff
you should be just as surprised by alex
jones because we live in a free society
so even i'm not defending him i don't
give a [ __ ] what anybody says get out
there say it he later predicted
epstein's islands
years before that came out all the
politicians who were who were promoting
the all the riots in 2020 and
celebrating businesses burning down
maura healey who's running for governor
here in massachusetts when they were
talking about all the businesses burning
she's like well that's how forests grow
and i i personally am still disgusted by
that and i hope she does not ever win
for
my mom she's going to turn this to
she's going to turn this into nazi
germany but let's bring back the blm
riots i got my mask ready to go all
right good
we'll no we're not doing those we'll do
some tape riding let's go burn [ __ ] down
until they freeze let's go let's go
it's called loot stores for tape being
banned and it's what what do they call
it they call it reparations spreading
the wealth these companies have enough
money i've had over a hundred thousand
emails of support since my banning and
the young people of the world today
are going to wake up from this banning
in a way that they've never woken up
from any others even trump's i really do
believe that because they're seeing
their hero banned for basically no
reason
and they're understanding that there's
something else going on and i think
they've overplayed their hand on this
particular yes this particular time
do you have a i mean
you say things that people
become hysterical about what if you
thought that why wouldn't you just say
it do you have any recourse
can you get back on social media well i
think if if the social media companies
had a genuine worry or a genuine
interest in men's mental health or in
female safety they would keep me on
social media and work with me to create
my message i hate to keep referencing it
but for all the people watching this who
want to really truly understand what
happened please go to freetopg.com
and you can see the whole one hour story
from start to finish of how i became
famous online and why i'm now being
unfairly targeted i don't think they're
ever going to allow me to come back onto
traditional social medias
and that's fine even if they did i'm not
sure if i'd be particularly interested
in investing in platforms that will just
destroy me and nuke me at will for
basically no reason they've literally
lost they lost their chance to have tate
on their platforms why would he even go
back everyone goes to rumble to listen
to him anyways i can't believe you
called this [ __ ] like a week ago with
the rumble stuff you started talking to
me about a conservative news platform
and i was like who gives a [ __ ] about
that and he gets banned and he makes it
the biggest thing and they're probably
paying him like he probably has equity
in that company because him moving there
is so big i had an offer from a very
fantastic platform called rumble oh i'm
sure if you're familiar youtubers i
haven't even seen this before but i'm
working closely with rumble now and i
can balance them on rumble rumble.com
tate speech
which is a play on hate speech because
we already know how that that's played
out for censorship oh
i didn't even put that together i think
this is going to be a really interesting
period of human history what the people
in charge of social media companies have
done
is they've banned the most popular
figure on the planet amongst a young
generation who have no problem
downloading a brand new app onto their
phones to watch their hero and it's not
like
an election or something where the
person you've banned will go away for a
few years the issues i discuss are
issues men face every day they're issues
men struggle with every day the advice i
give is advice they're always going to
want daily because it's it's reacting to
the problems which life feeds them and
they're not going to just forget about
me and hope and and just think oh i'll
just forget about him then and be
hopeless they're going to follow me
wherever i go
and i think that there's going to be a
genuine mass exodus away from these
platforms because they ban me which is
very bad for them and it's bad for
humanity as a whole everything could
have been fantastic four or five days
ago
there was no problems i had social media
accounts and everything was fine but
they decided to do this so i'm gonna
move to rumble and i'm gonna continue my
mission of philanthropy i'm not doing
anything other than just telling young
men how i became a man of substance and
how they can do the same thing
you
probably made some of these companies
mad with reviews on covid
so sum up for us if you would
what you think the response to covid
globally did to the populations of the
west
yes so i certainly made my mag of my
views on covid i don't want to go to
conspiracy theory and i would also never
kill myself let me just say that here
for for
for the record but at the time of covet
at the time of covet first being
announced
my brother and i decided to we sat and
had a very logical conversation and we
sat and said we're two young
fighting age males if kovid can kill us
then the world is over it's zombie
apocalypse time
so there's no point hiding 100 percent
if these two professional kickboxers are
getting even like sniffles from kovid
we're screwed so my brother and i flew
to stockholm sweden now i don't know if
many people know this but sweden never
closed down stockholm and sweden had
never closed down
never made you wear masks never mandated
no that was not as much as i was
watching the news glued to the news
because what else was there to do
they never reported that because we
would have all been sitting here going
why why are we doing this what's
happening here you know what's crazy is
when i went down to school last august
and then i came back to boston for like
thanksgiving or winter break and people
had masks on and they were busting my
balls going in the stores i was like you
people are literally [ __ ] there's
nothing going on down south like how are
you bugging out about this are you just
down there living life this is a joke
going down to florida for months at a
time
you got mayor wu making making vaccine
rules at the end of 2021 is that a joke
they didn't kill as if they didn't kill
the economy enough then to make vaccine
requirements to even walk into a
restaurant it was disgusting and she
should be ashamed of herself
that's yeah that's a boston expression
because we hate our mayor when the
republican states were still closed
stockholm sweden was wide open with all
night clubs and a party scene like
you've never seen
and we lived in sweden for three solid
months with zero restrictions zero worry
or interest in copen it was like the
world was completely normal
and from there when we left obviously
kobut was still going on in a
neighboring country you go to germany
and they were having full panic attacks
genuine panic attacks didn't have a mask
on and it was just very obvious to me i
was like i've spent the last three
months ignoring this and i'm fine and
now i'm in germany surrounded by panic
attacks
and endless mass this i literally
couldn't take it seriously the entire
time for kobe not even since the start
yeah we were total covert [ __ ] we
you know what we did you were you were a
little weird at first but in the
beginning they said they said it
was two or three weeks to flatten the
curve and i was like we could do that no
problem we did it two weeks okay so we
did it and right at that two-week mark
you were like when they're going oh we
got to keep doing this and you were like
it's for your safety i got my friends
and i was like ah i don't know and then
we both just looked each other like all
right basically to hell with it and he
started going out and i started having
my friends over and we're all hanging
out and everything was normal and i went
outside without a mask people walking
down the street alone as we all know
with masks on it was the stupidest thing
ever
and i never put a mask on unless i had
to because i had to go into a store and
half the time i walked out of the house
without the mask never never became an
accessory that i remembered so we just
kept living and look at us we made it
through we lived i did catch covet uh
earlier this year in 2022 and i had long
covered meaning i just had fatigue and
for about six weeks it wasn't really
that bad so
i was lucky i know people had it much
worse but
it was just overblown beyond belief the
decimation of your income the fact you
can't go get a doctor's appointment for
a genuine ailment or a genuine risk
answer
the fact that you can't see your loved
ones in their final days these things
are far more destructive than the common
cold
i think that what they're doing is is
unfair i think it's a massive
overreaction and this is based on my
personal experience and i think at the
time there was a lot of pushback but i
would like to think now that 99 the
world cl was totally right
you know it's kind of funny tucker i'll
tell you when at the height of covet i
used to say to my brother
how will people struggle with the
cognitive dissonance when this is all
over
because covet is still out there
nothing's gone away
the thing that we were all hiding from
is still right there out there to get
you but now everyone walks around and
they're not scared of it anymore and i'm
like that hasn't even clicked through
people's heads that literally people
haven't even comprehended that how
insane is that he said the thing
everyone was afraid of is still right
here kova didn't go away yeah it's crazy
it's so crazy and they all just believe
getting it even with all their shots and
their boosters they just keep getting
covered and they say okay yeah it did
help it does help people to not get it
as badly
and these are the same ones that are
teaching kids from kindergarten up till
senior year of college and these are the
same ones teaching you how to become a
man and make money and and be
independent these are the same people
that you're supposed to learn all those
things from [ __ ] that that's just such a
thing
it is such a scam here we are it's
august 2022 and the mayor of dc just
announced that any student that wants
that is unvaccinated cannot attend
washington dc public schools and she has
no online option so if you don't want
your kids to get faxed for any reason
they get no education they get no
education and we all know as a matter of
fact that um the black community is the
most unfa vaccinated population in
america which you know by you know
proportionally that's neither here nor
there but here she is hurting that
population more than any that's
hilarious
they're not smart enough they're not
smart enough to go and get an id but
they're smart enough to get vaccinated
and if they don't get vaccinated they
just don't get an education yeah you
just you you just let the little kids
let all the kids just run around the
streets because their parents have to
work to keep to keep a roof over their
heads
it's so insane that and so she's so
there are going to be people who get
their kids vaccinated just to go to
school just to go to school so they can
go to work they literally had to
incentivize people with ball games and
flights oh they were giving away they
were giving away money yeah tickets
gifts when once they saw they were
trying to like pay me to take it you get
a 100 voucher at the school gift at the
school library i'm like what the [ __ ] do
i look like to you that's not gonna be
the reason i get a shot for a [ __ ]
couple books i wouldn't i would like to
find out the results on those on those
campaigns and see if they were effective
like how many people were like oh gee i
get a mom movie you have no clue how
many people did that just for the free
notebooks and [ __ ] especially down in
florida kids work for like 850 an hour
they're like the brokest [ __ ] i
know are people critical enough to
analyze themselves and say for a year of
my life i was deathly afraid of
something now i'm exposing myself to
said thing and i'm not afraid anymore
the media tricked me and i was a fool
but they're not they're they don't even
seem to self-analyze and go i got
tricked
they're just like oh okay next thing
hate andrew now
it's npcs they're gta characters so i i
just
of rich people under covid you're one of
them to everybody else what did you
notice about that it seemed like a
two-tiered response
yeah so the story was very simple i was
flying inside of europe there's a lot of
low-cost air
care
air carriers it's only low-cost
primarily there's not much first class
business class anything like that and i
was flying
and my experience was plagued by endless
paperwork wearing a mask put the mask
over your nose every time you eat you
have to put the mask on in between
uh i got told off for not having the
mask up high enough i got told off for
drinking too long because my mask wasn't
on pure panic and chaos and because i'm
fortunate enough to be fiscally secure
from there i decided i'll just buy
private jets from now on and when i
bought a private jet there was no masks
no paperwork no mask at the airport when
i landed my air stewardess was not
wearing a mask my pilot was not wearing
a mask covid didn't exist once i bought
a private jet
maybe if you're rich enough covert can't
take maybe cover's scared of money i'm
not sure but it seems that everyone it's
for the brokeees it's for the brookies
if you even look at the people making
these laws it's a joke they put on their
mask for the camera they're fooling you
it's a [ __ ] train oh they were all
caught it's a legit prank
they're having massive parties the what
was it the governor or someone of new
york made rules where you couldn't have
people over for thanksgiving and then he
gets caught with like 50 people over his
house these people are the biggest
muslims in california out at some luxury
dinner when everyone else was being
forced to stay home i mean it just goes
on not only do they not care about you
they're lying to your face it is a
literal prank
i say that word way too much literal
whatever just keep going yeah i'll work
on my vocabulary and then i'd come to
let's say england and see my friend who
couldn't go see his dying grandmother
because of a coveted restriction that's
truly sad that's truly criminal i don't
it's really crazy what's happened and
how the world's just moved on and the
cognitive dissonance that people
don't have enough respect for themselves
and for the truth to analyze how they
were so easily fooled it it's really sad
heartbreaking my uncle died alone in his
hospital room because they wouldn't let
anybody in to see him really and that
was the last thing on earth he wanted
and he was truly the warmest nicest
person in our family and he had to pass
away alone like that with a if there was
a nurse in the room she was she looked
like a science fiction robot with all
her ppp
personal protection on so he is so right
and we knew it was wrong while it was
happening so wrong but what could you
even done what could we have done maybe
that was the beginning of me being
disliked by just pointing out my human
experiences during the the pandemic
last question
because
unpack we called it the scam demo since
the start i don't even care i'll say
whatever i want on the internet at this
point so yeah i've always i've always
called this [ __ ] a scam people don't
have enough respect for themselves to
analyze the ways they were lied to
what is that's an interesting sentence
what does that mean
just explain it means that if i was
fooled
if i was one of the people on social
media who was genuinely purporting the
idea that people should be locked in
their homes nearly indefinitely because
of a common cold
if i was fooled like that i would feel
deep shame
and i would really take some time and
look in the mirror and analyze who
managed to trick me to such a degree how
my mind got so poisoned how i got
plagued to such a level and i would feel
deep shame because i would understand
that my words had repercussions and that
i have been purporting
a worldview or a narrative which has
been genuinely destructive and i would
sit there and i would be upset and angry
and sad and i think i can't believe
they've managed to do that to me and i
can't believe that i bought into it and
did it to other people but unfortunately
there's people out here who a year ago
were running around screaming at other
people in the street to wear a mask who
are now not wearing a mask themselves
despite the fact that covid still exists
and they don't have enough self-respect
or enough respect for the truth to even
feel sorry or shameful for what they
used to do
it's incredible to me don't you have any
ounce of honor
like look what you've done to the world
you were screaming in people's faces now
you're out here
yourself it's truly amazing the
cognitive dissonance that people
experience and it's the same now there
are people watching videos of me saying
i'm a misogynist
and no matter how many times i prove
them otherwise
because the daily mail said the word
misogynist it just simply must be true
and these people are so deeply stuck
inside of the matrix that
it's it's it's difficult to even what
kind of what can what can we do as
rational adults you must struggle with
this yourself tucker how many times have
you tried to tell the truth to people
they're so stuck inside of the matrix
that they don't even realize that there
is a matrix
that's literally what that's what he
means they're so stuck inside they don't
even realize that they're inside the
matrix
i recognize at least that i'm still not
fully out of the matrix yet like there's
a lot of stuff that i need to do i need
to get my multiple pass reports multiple
bank accounts literally be able to be
untouchable by any greater force like i
recognize that and i'm working to get
out of it but these people are just so
brainwashed they have no clue they have
literally zero clue and the next thing
the government says they're gonna
operate on it and and buy it completely
how and believe it the monkey pox thing
are you kidding me who is actually
getting scared of this [ __ ] right now i
i don't know how i even got here now i'm
on your show for being a researcher
it's mind-bending
if i have a question about what someone
believes i think the first step is to
ask that person and i think most people
are willing to say what they believe and
i take them at i take them out there
where did i take you at yours i asked
you do you hate women you said no i
don't and you explain your views on
women but you are on the record saying
that you hate tap water
and i want you to explain your bias
against tap water yeah so in my long
career online i was trying to say some
things like i said i've said many things
for comedic effect and my brother and i
come from very humble beginnings we
started with absolutely no money and now
we're doing kind of okay for ourselves
and in one of our lifestyle blogs
the waiter asked if we wanted sparkling
water or still water and i said only
sparkling i don't drink still water and
the person we were with said why don't
you drink still water and i said because
the government will give you that for
free you have to buy sparkling water and
i'm rich and it was a joke
and it's just blown up and now rich
people drink sparkling water and tap
water is for brokies and that's just
kind of how it's gone i'm a victim of my
own success i've been massively
massively viral everything i've ever
said has become a thing
and uh some of that's good some of
that's funny and then also a lot that's
been used against me in this false
narrative but i want to tell you
something that's that's actually kind of
scary about this banning
it all came so hard and so fast
that i don't know if they all just
follow each other i don't know if
they're all influenced by each other i
don't know if there's someone above them
all
i don't know
that's tonic water that's not sparkling
water it's sparkling though it does it
has bubbles that doesn't make it sparkly
what are you afraid of a couple bubbles
when they go to cancel you ladies and
gentlemen
it comes hard and fast
she said your facebook then your
instagram then your gmail then your
discord then your website hosting then
your domain name
like then your payment processor then
your bank that like it's just like in
real time you're watching your phone and
apps just exploding boom boom boom he
said his domain and all that stuff did
that happen i thought it was just the
social media accounts that banned him
like bank he's talking about bank
accounts everything i don't really know
yeah i don't know if he's talking in
general that that's what happens to some
people which it has look what they did
in in canada when people were were
donating to the truckers the freedom
truckers and they the canadian
government came in and froze people's
bank accounts frozen you can't donate to
a cause you believe for free speech what
are you granted about it's just
hilarious because people think that that
[ __ ] won't happen and it literally will
if you stay stuck inside the matrix did
happen it's so funny in canada could you
imagine saying something and having the
government shut your entire life down
all of it you know that money you worked
for you couldn't even go buy groceries
or or put gas in the car to leave the
country nothing i think that is
hilarious that these same people wanted
to move there too and these same people
vote for those people again and again
and again oh they won't do that as you
can
i don't want to go conspiracy theorists
i'm just telling people what i've been
through it's really crazy
and uh if they'll do it to me for saying
women can't park a car
which was a joke
sorry world
and they'll do it to basically anybody
and you have to be prepared for that and
that's one of the reasons why i've moved
to rumble now because i've had long
conversations with senior management
there and they promised that i can make
jokes
without being destroyed and annihilated
which is quite refreshing so i very much
look forward to continuing my
oh yeah we are on rumble now so i'll
drop the link in the description and
make sure to follow us there we're not
going to be on youtube much longer
there's no way well we're going to stay
here until we get kicked out yeah and
we'll go to rumble and then well we're
going to be every let's just do rumble
also and we'll be all over tech talk
soon rumble.com tatespeech and i know
for a fact that my young fans will come
with me so this is just the beginning of
a max mass exodus away from the
influence of control by tech companies
because they decided that they didn't
want to allow the most respected and
famous person of the time currently
things change
for young men to make a joke or to be on
their platforms and it's going to be a
very interesting few years from from
here on out
i'll say this no sin you've committed is
half as threatening as what they just
did to you that is threatening and we
appreciate your taking all this time to
talk to us andrew tate interesting
interesting conversation thank you very
much
thank you bro
thank you bro chuck carlson today's name
in the show episodes three days a week
on fox nation we'll be back every week
night 8 pm on the fox news channel
good night tucker good night tucker
i have a taco coffee mug you know that
right that's lit
well that was interesting so
thanks everybody all right say something
funny no no bye
oh my
[Music]
last god yeah